in the last set of videos we've
hopefully familiarize ourselves with the
different ways that a company can raise
capital it can do it through debt or
equity and we learned that debt
securities are often called bonds and
equity securities you're probably
familiar with those are stocks and then
I left you with a cliffhanger and let me
let me draw it so I don't get ahead of
myself so these are the assets of a
company and it was able to generate
these assets so there's a couple of ways
you can generate assets you can get
investors through equity and we've done
several videos on that you start with
the angel investors or maybe your rich
uncle and then you've entered good
venture capitalists and you do an
initial public offering and you can do
follow-on offerings and so on and so
forth now we see government's will buy
equity in you if you are a bank that's
too big to fail but we'll do a whole
playlist on that so equity that's one
way that you can get cash or get capital
so that you can buy assets to run your
business the other way is you can borrow
money from people so the equity holders
they become this these are actually the
owners of the company so you might have
been part of the equity holder you have
to sell some of the equity or sell some
shares in your company for someone else
to give money and then they become kind
of like your partner and the other way
is you can borrow money let me draw that
that will just put generally as
liability debt isn't the only kind of
liability but that's a pretty reasonable
simplification for now there's other
things and general liability means you
owe something to somebody in the future
liabilities not liability well yeah
these are liabilities so these are
liabilities and we'll assume right now
that your debt is your main liability
you might have other liabilities you
might have some type of legal liability
where someone is suing you or you know
you had sprayed asbestos on a bunch of
playgrounds thinking that it was
actually good for the playground
equipment and now you know there's all
of this liability because well you get
the idea
but for now on we'll have the
simplification that debt is your
liability and we said well you know
there's quite different kinds of debt if
you securitize and it's often a bond
right that'd be a certificate that says
it's an IOU from a company it'll pay you
coupons or interest and so forth or you
could also just get regular bank debt
where you owe the bank money and I left
you with the question the last time
around
I said let's say this company goes into
bankruptcy and let's say that these
assets aren't worth what we think they
are right in this world if we just have
to sell off these assets fine the equity
you know the debt guys would get paid
off and then the equity guys would get
left over with whatever else so let's
say if this was if on our books so
whenever you hear things like Book value
and I've done a couple of videos on Book
value vs. market value but the book
value is essentially what you have it on
your on your accounting books you say
that this is worth 10 million dollars
right let's say we've bought land and
factories and whatever else worth 10
million dollars let's say your debt is
six million dollars six million dollars
and your equity would be worth four
million dollars and let's say for
whatever reason the economy turns south
or you know maybe this was some type of
you know business that's now not viable
so it's going to go to bankruptcy and
I'll get a little bit more specific on
the different types of bankruptcy but
we're assuming liquidation right
actually I'll just get specific right
now and sorry for the diet so when we
say bankruptcy and bankruptcy is is
probably it's a very common word and I
think most people have a general sense
what it means they know it's bad and it
means to some degree that a company
can't operate as it was before but
there's a lot of confusion over what it
means there's actually two types of
bankruptcy there's liquidation
liquidation and that's meant essentially
saying that you know what this business
doesn't it make any sense it doesn't
make sense to have the employees and run
the factories you're never going to make
any money so you might as well just sell
everything you have you liquidate it all
that's one type and that falls in the
category of chapter 7 and we're just
talking about corporate bank bankruptcy
right now there's also personal
bankruptcy and we'll maybe we'll do a
couple of videos on that it might be
especially relevant in in this economy
well the other type is reorganization or
restructuring reorganization or
restructuring and restructuring says you
know what this Factory here it's
actually making something useful it's
Jax regenerating money and actually we
can get more value for what we have here
if we keep it running and we'll just
keep it run
and we'll restructure the company and
usually that means changing this hand
this side of it so maybe we'll cancel
some debt and all of that and well show
you how that's done in in a reasonably
fair way but just to get just to
understand kind of a simplified scenario
let's take liquidation into
consideration so let's say that this was
my let's say that this was my website
selling shoes online and then all of a
sudden people have stopped wearing shoes
it's it's just it's just gone out of
fashion so it makes no sense anymore to
sell shoes online so I'm just going to
liquidate my assets my real estate that
I might have my warehouses etc etc and
my question that I left you with in the
last video is who gets it so let's say
when we liquidate it so we go into
bankruptcy and it's essentially all of
the assets are taken into possession by
the Bankruptcy Court they're going to
sell these assets and let's say when
they sell them they don't get 10 million
dollars for these assets they only get
they only get I don't mean they only get
5 million dollars for them right I paid
for I'm thinking that they were useful
in some way but they end up not to be so
my assets let me see if I erase them let
me erase some things you know I just
realized when I talked earlier about you
know there's two ways to raise capital
there's a third way to raise capital
right you can sell shares you can issue
debt you can borrow money obviously the
third way is actually just make money
right once you start a company hopefully
you generate earnings and that'll also
generate cash or capital that you can
reinvest in the business and we'll talk
about that but I just want to make it
clear that that's obviously the best way
to generate capital for your business is
when the business itself generates
capital so let's say that these assets
when you actually sell them off aren't
worth 10 million dollars anymore
but they're worth we make the pointer
smaller they're worth $5,000,000
$5,000,000 so my question in the last
video is who gets this five million
dollars do you somehow split it evenly
between all of these people or does one
of them get more of it or one of them
gets less of it and I think you'll get a
sense but based on how I where I took
the five million out of who gets the
money it's the debt holders and the way
I drew it right here you can kind of
view it as as you go up in this
direction you're getting more senior
more senior or if you're going down and
this way you're getting more junior and
seniority when you talk about a
company's capital structure is just you
know what if there's anything left who
gets their money first and even within
the debt you'll have different layers of
debt though there might be different
debt holders who have different levels
of seniority so this one might be called
senior secured debt senior secured debt
senior means they're high up on the
stack they're the one of the first
people to get their their money and
secured means that there's actually some
collateral on the assets side that they
get if the company can't pay so maybe
this is like a piece of land right so
just in kind of our everyday personal
finance world your mortgage is actually
secured debt it's secured by the
collateral of your home if you can't pay
the debt the bank comes and takes your
home it forecloses on the property so
that's what secured means it means that
there's some collateral and in the event
of a bankruptcy this guy can immediately
go and get the collateral that his debt
is secured by so this is considered a
very very senior form of debt senior
secured then you might have here you
might have senior senior unsecured
unsecured senior and there's a lot of
words around you know senior junior
subordinated and all of that but this is
a good a sense that there's just a
hierarchy here some people are the first
people to get the money and then
whatever is money left goes to this
person then if there's any money left it
goes to this person and then if there's
anything left it goes to this person and
once you're in bankruptcy court it does
tend to be a negotiation between the
different you can almost view a buckets
of debt and we'll do a more complicated
example in the future on that we'll
actually delve into the details of
bankruptcy but this is a general notion
that the senior guys get made whole
first then the more junior guys gets
whatever's left and so on and so forth
and if there's no money for the equity
there's no money for the equity and that
makes sense right because the debt
holders you know all day we're getting
their upside was just interest right so
they're also should get limited downside
and event things turn bad equity holders
they kind of took a gamble things were
great they would get all of the upside
and now that things turned bad they take
a lot of the downside and they're
actually lucky that they don't owe money
that's actually the I guess you could
call it the beauty of a corporate
structure that you have little
liability and sometimes in history these
people would actually owe the difference
they would actually owe this extra
million dollars that they can they'd all
go to debtors prison and all that but
we'll talk more about it in the future
so anyway just going back on the
different tranches of debt or buckets of
debt so we could call this senior
unsecured and that means that they're
still senior they're still fairly high
up the seniority ladder but they're
unsecured there's no particular assets
that they can go run but as long as
there's enough for them don't get it so
let's let me put some numbers here so
let's say there was I don't know one
million of senior secured let's say
there's two million of senior unsecured
and let's say that this is two million
of subordinated subordinated
subordinated just means they're not
senior unsecured unsecured so in this
reality what will happen is the
Bankruptcy Court to liquidate all of
this stuff and then they'll handled out
an order of seniority these guys get
their million dollars back so they're
made whole and they probably charge a
lower interest rate because they didn't
perceive their risk that high to begin
with these guys right here the senior
unsecured they'll get the next two
million and then there's 1 million
dollars left right and that 1 million
dollars will go to these dis support
native debts so they'll get 50% of their
money back so they took a little bit of
a hit but that's okay because when
things were good they probably got
higher interest to to compensate them
for the risk usually as you go as you
get more and more junior and you take on
more risk you get more upside or more
interest and in this case the equity
holders get nothing they get wiped out
so it just goes to zero so that's that's
the answer to the question I I said who
gets the money well it's it's the debt
holders get first dibs and if if there
was actually let's see if there was I
don't know if there was 7 million
dollars here instead of 5 million then
you would have paid so if this was 7 you
would have paid the 6 off completely and
then the equity holders would have
gotten 1 million dollars and so they
would have gotten something if there was
enough money to hand it to them anyway
in the next video I'll cover this was
liquidation where we just say this isn't
worth running let's just give it all
away or let's sell it and give it back
to our
are our creditors the next video I'll
talk about reorganization where we say
hey you know what this business is a
good business it just has too many
liabilities and see you in the next
video